la figura be es una copia a escala de la
figura y queremos saber cuál es el
factor de escala para pasar de la figura
a la figura ve pausa en el vídeo y vean
si pueden resolver solamente necesitamos
observar los lados correspondientes y
pensar en que tanto lo han escalado por
ejemplo este lado corresponde a este
lado en la figura ve y podemos ver que
aquí tiene una longitud igual a 2
mientras que aquí tiene una longitud de
1 2 3 4 5 6 así que al parecer este lado
ha sido escalado por un factor de 3
entonces si la figura de es realmente
una copia a escala cada lado debe de
estar escalado por un factor de 3 y
podemos verificarlo no en todos lados
pero si nos dicen que estas dos figuras
son copias a escala tenemos que
verificar si es el caso por ejemplo este
lado corresponde a esta base
ahora este lado mide 3 por lo tanto si
lo escalamos por un factor de 3 debemos
multiplicar eso por 3 y esto debe de
tener una longitud igual a 9
veamos si es el caso 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y 9
así que como pueden ver la figura b es
una copia a escala de la figura
y el factor de escala es 3 hagamos otro
ejemplo aquí nos dicen que israel hizo
una copia a escala del siguiente
cuadrilátero el uso un factor de escala
menor a 1 ok y después nos preguntan
cuál sería la longitud del lado que
corresponde a a d
este es el lado ave que tiene una
longitud de 16 unidades en el
cuadrilátero original cuál sería la
longitud del lado que corresponde a a d
en la copia a escala del cuadrilátero
bueno ya nos dijeron que es un factor de
escala menor a 1 así que este lado será
en hora 16 y todo lo demás también es
escalado por el mismo factor por lo
tanto el cuadrilátero resultante es algo
como esto pero esta es mi versión
dibujada a mano alzada aquí la clave es
que si nuestro factor de escala es menor
a 1 este lado es menor a 16 unidades
entonces veamos nuestras opciones aquí
nos dicen elige tres respuestas los
invito a que pause en el vídeo y decidan
cuál de estas opciones podrían ser si el
factor de escala es menor a uno bueno
simplemente tenemos que ver cuáles son
menores a 16 unidades esta opción es
menor a 16 esta es menor a 16 y ésta es
menor a 16 y esas son las únicas tres
opciones menores a 16 32 unidades
corresponden a un factor de escala de 2
y 64 unidades son de un factor de escala
de 4 y claramente no son factores de
escala menores a 1
este es el final del vídeo